with hit songs in each of the last five
decades
music legend garth brooks has won nearly
every award
imaginable thanks in part to an
infectious enthusiasm that spans genres
music is what starts my day you came in
and you're singing you
make me feel like a
natural woman yeah
melody kills you right it's a beautiful
night voting moon dance right
it's that real pretty stuff and then
you've got sinatra
and you've got our version of sinatra
which is george strait very
conversational right
well excuse me but i
think you've got my chair
oh how cool is that but garth just think
about that when you go
how cool is that i think that's what
people feel about you
how cool is he honestly that's sweet how
cool is it because i'm the last guy that
would think cool would be on my
thing you have to help me understand
that have you looked in the mirror
have you listened to your songs well
looking in the mirror is one of the
things that mystifies me
yeah these are not i'm not beautiful not
fan i'm not
you know and and the voice is not of you
know
cinematic quality my curse
is i'm not special my blessing
is i'm not special
i get to be the average guy
the youngest of six kids from a small
town in oklahoma
gars mother gave up her own music career
to raise a family
shortly before her death she told cbs
news she tried to steer her son
away from music did you want him to
follow in your footsteps
lord no more i begged him not to so i
went to the
recruiting office there in stillwater
for the marine corps because my father
was a marine
and i thought i'd surprise my dad but
telling him i went
his first worst garth you don't want to
do that i think every parent
wants something different for their
child because every parent has seen
the dark side of everything but that
didn't deter you that your mom because
you were very close to your mother that
didn't deter you that she didn't want
you to do this
if you knew my mom garth don't get in
this business
wink wink but after playing local bars
all through college he left oklahoma for
nashville
a trip that lasted just 24 hours
i go to nashville thinking everything's
going to be straw hats and goose neck
trailers right
and everything's suit and ties it's
business i'm not ready for that
back home brooks married his college
sweetheart sandy mall
got a band together and on his second
trip to music city
he landed a record deal in less than a
year
his first record went gold
and his career took off in the 90s garth
you were
unstoppable how did you handle
all of that thing what did it mean to
you i probably didn't handle it well a
nation watches you grow up
right yeah so you're going to make
decisions that you go man i wish i could
take that one back but the truth is now
if changing anything then meant any part
of now would change
no thank you brooks embraced that
philosophy on life from one of his
earliest hits
the dance a thousand people can hear it
and each one will take
whatever it is to them from that song
it's sweet so there's the blessing and
the curse yeah
the blessing is you found the song that
defines you some artists never get to
the curse is it was way back off that
first record
by 1999 brooks had sold over 100 million
albums
and brought millions of new fans into
country music
but with his marriage falling apart he
announced
he would be walking away once children
come into the mix
children take the lead that's it they
didn't want to come in this place
it wasn't their choice we brought them
in
so even though sandy and i were not
going to be able to complete our
marriage
we still had our children to raise the
country music audience has given you
everything
now you just simply ask them i'm going
to go home and raise my babies
the big surprise was never ever thinking
you're going to get to be led back in
you know it does seem to be a recurring
thing with you that you seem to feel
lucky or surprised that people show up
do you
do you still feel i mean yeah because
when you don't know
why they show up you don't know if
they'll show up again
were you nervous when you came back
after 14 years i would love to have been
at that first show
yeah you were scared scared to death and
the people were so
sweet but garth they let you back in oh
my god did they ever
in a big big big way you go on tour and
the sales go through the roof
after 14 years 15 you were miss garth
roots
country is the best place to be because
one you have the most little
audience there can possibly be and they
will
wait for you right and
there began my life your kids are all
out of high school yeah you're with the
love of your life
and this is the rest of your life as far
as you can see
what gets better than that yeah that
love is his wife and fellow country
singer tricia yearwood
the two first met in the 1980s while
married to other people
so you uh kind of become friends buddies
every time she comes in to sing on every
record you know you start getting kind
of
sweaty and and just love the way she
smelled how does she smell
it's such a loving thing to say she
smells like nothing's impossible
and she really does despite all his
success
brooks isn't ready to slow down after
accepting his kennedy center medallion
he made a bold promise this is going to
start making what we've done
hopefully it looks small you wake up in
the morning you're breathing then god's
got a plan for you what are you going to
do with it
are you going to be a warrior are you
going to be a retired guy
so that that's your your that's your
question every morning